[拍手]
r
はじめまして可能水と申しますちょっといろいろな店主と出るの遅くなったんですけど
あ
これからブーブーんですけども
ブーブー的に良い皆さんにお話をしていくだけだとちょっと面白くないかなと思うん
ですよ
なので今回ので僕はもう君と参加し路線皆さんとリョンと一緒にサテン今回
12ちょっと質問したりするところがありますのでみなさんぜひ参加してください
よろしくお願いします
たとえ
僕が生活をしていて思うことがいっぱいあっあーっ
夜中にはだいたい3つのタイプの人間がいるなって思うんです
まず1つ目まず一つ目は毎日の生活を豊かにそして主体的に楽しんでいる道から見た
ことあるのかんだと思うんですけど
こういった毎日を主体的に過ごしている人
集めは心の増加で地帯になりたいな
主体的が痛いな思っていながらもう
それがなかなか行動に移す結びつかずに結果的に自動的になってしまっている日
裏例えばアルバイトとかねぇ
園児服を入れられてしまって結果的に自分のやりたかったことをする時間がなくなって
しまって
でもちょっと版神戸いけないのでいやいやシッポに
はい
そういう人の事を押します
そして三つ目は周りの環境まあいう人に常に流されてしまって自分の判断基準がない
結果的に常に自動的になってしまっていると
これは例えばと回しマリのをしていて俺これにするから応援しよう生みたいな友達の
提案に胸にも考えないで
ああいいねそうしよう感じで反応してしまうと
この3体感です
毎日を主体的に過ごしていると
機体で耳が痛いけど自動てにあるん
そして常に周りに流されてしまうそうできないと
では今いらっしゃる皆さんにお伺いしたいんですけれどもこの3つのタイプだったら
みなさんどれに当てはまるんだっていうのをちょっと願いしたいです
雨方には妓房に座ってる人とか僕全員見えるんで安定あげないとか言ったら
ボラーとデスネチョンで一人残らず話しかけ今
宜しくお願いします
1本目3
など詰めに行きましょう前上社駅に過ごしてるな
自分の中で感じていると訴えてください
すごいですねありがとうございますもうもっとまんじゅう中にしてください
一つ目です
したいる磨いたいるを自動的になってしまってなんて言うと失態でください
会津山マスターの称号にも近づくなっていますね
3つ目常に周りに流されてしまう
常に受動的な人花思う人はあってあげてください
おはようございます
今回の僕のテッド遠くパイプは
未だにスタン2つ tsutaya で気になりたいけど
自動的になってしまっている人そして常にま
周りに流されている自動的な人
頭にタイプの人たちに特にオハナシ者いないん
上的ないって a
裏を返すとあっ松山社内に自動的にとって裏を返すと伝える8タイプ町の僕はです
主体的ないって言ってどういう問題があるのが皆さん思うんですけれども僕が方に
地帯的ではないことには大きく2つの問題があります
先ず一つねそれは自分な吸収できるはずの知識が吸収できなくなって自分のためになら
ないということです
大学の授業を思い浮かべてみてください
いわゆる楽かんだからトーカー
フェイスとが楽だから通っただから授業はそんなにちゃんと聞かなくていいやみたいな
感じで
教師の話へ内容を生前話してる内容をもうみんカラ姫聞き流してしまう
そういった人はもしかしたら将来役に立つかもしれないこと
近いうちに必要になってしまうような知識をうっかり聞き逃したりし得るかもしれませ
ん
2つ目の問題点は自分にとってのベストチョイスができないということです
前の環境や周りの意見にずっと泣かされてしまうと自分が本当にやりたいことだったり
自分がやらなければいけない方法をすることができなかったり帰り激化としてもそこに
至るまでステップはすごく難しくなってしまうんです
この2つです
自分のためにならないですとチョイスができない
こうした問題点を解決して毎日の生活をより豊かにそしてより主体的にしていくために
は一体どうすればいいでしょうか
それは自分だけの判断基準を持ってその判断基準に沿って毎日を過ごしていくことが
大切です
そして今回僕も皆さんにご提案するのはその判断基準として楽しいというものを使おう
ということです
楽しい
これは今回らしい皆さんも参加されていない皆さんを全ての人が持っている感情ですが
この感情は自分の中にある絶対的なもので周りに影響されることって実はそんなに多く
ないんです
なのでこの楽しいという判断基準を持って毎日の生活を過ごすことによって結果的に
自分の身がしっかりと出来て主体的に行動してそして毎日の生活が豊かになる
そういうことにつながります
僕自身この他の支援という判断基準を持って毎日を過ごしていますが
この判断基準を取り入れるようになったのは小学生の方でした
僕は小学6年生のころ12歳の頃から
ガジェット等でブログをずっと名しています
小学生の頃から文章を書いてそれをインターネット上に載せて皆さんに選んだとなる
そういう経験教えたんですがあるとき
twitter で全く知らない人が僕の下準備で
やこの記事面白いぞみたいなコメントをつけてシェアしてくれたんです
その時に深く感じたのは
あ文章を自分好きなように書いてそれを読んでもらえて
さあにコメントを付けてない米中のプロセスってめちゃくちゃふぁんしーなー
そういう感動でした
桃源台県がきっかけで僕はいつしか
日々の生活の中から楽しい感じるものを見つけそれに連中するそういったテクニックを
身につけることができました
パナスターを基準にすることによって物事が長続きして続けることによって新たな
つながりあなたが変わり新たな知識が広まる
そういった知識つながりをさらに清めてもっと楽しんでやっていることによって新たな
楽しみを見つけて
さえに続けることが出ている
こうした楽しみのサイクルを積む入れることが結果的に僕もみなさんの生活も豊かに
なっていることで使えます
じゃあ思い実際に今どうなんだよということで僕がここ数年で年中してすごく上達した
な感じているものについてお話させてください
それは写真です
この写真
この写真は僕が五年前高校1年生の頃に京都で撮影した写真です
たくさんチェックをやってみました
細かいところいるとキリがないんですけれども写真が平行になっていなくて頭は
ちょっと曲がってたり
アンク者さんの橋の飛びしていたり黒く塗りつぶさまったり
おまけに右の山こんな人の方もん
もっとうまくクエの本当に違いんですけれどもとにかくこの写真は僕にとってそんなに
良くない車線なんです
転機になったのは高校2年生のだろう
沖縄桁修学旅行です
本当に僕は父親が市があるカメラを借りてきました
僕自身沖縄に行くの初めての経験だったので
の景色が僕にとって初めての景色だった
これをもちろん原因なんですがそれよりも一眼レフカメラと写真っていうのが今まで
自分が撮影してきた
どの写真よりもすごくきれい感動さんです
ただに修学旅行中はポッド写真8
クラスメイトの街へ学年の友達に
なるべくリアルダーインで共有をしていたんですけれども
そうやって写真を送った受け取ってくれた多くの人がいやお前の写真
マズいな感じですぐを込めてくれたんです
この時に感じたみんなから喜ばれるという経験と自分が一眼レフカメラ見ないと感動
こういった経験から写真を撮るのってすごく楽しいな
思うようになって方向卒業してから音楽的に写真に取り組むようになりました
この写真から5年号
去年の春に目黒ガール撮影した弱くない自信が
こちらです
自分でのマンなんですけど目指し経営者ですかね
まあそういう反応までも3階でございます
高校卒業生前にナイター写真を撮るすごく楽しいなと思う感情から写真が好きな人
写真を撮るのが好きな人写真の機材を集めるのが好きな人こういった人たちとたくさん
つながることができてそういった人たちと一緒に写真を撮りに出かけたりそういう性質
から写真のテクニック大当たり
そうしたことが罪とさんっで楽しみの財布を積みな
それが結果的にこういった写真を撮影できたことに下がりました
今ではインスタグラムとかで僕の撮った写真を紹介してくれるようなこともちょっと
ずつ増えてきたのでこういったところから
また写真を撮るん楽しいな行く感情を見つけてあぁターンサイクルを紡いでいきたいな
と思ってます
では
ここまで僕の花ショットをしてみましたが皆さんが
日々の生活の中から楽しいなーって思うものをつまみ出してそこに包括しているために
は一体どうすればいいでしょうか
先ほどの楽しみの際文です
このサイクルルート左上のきっかけの部分になっています
今日いらしてくださっている大学生の方にも社会人の方でも毎日多くの
やらなければいけないことやりたいことをしたいことすごくたくさんまずでこの方から
自分が本当にやっていて楽しいなと思うものを見つけるのはすごく難しい子はずです
なんで今回のペット豆腐の最後に僕が小学校6年生の頃からずっとやっている方法を
みなさんに伝えします
必要なのは大きな紙と1本の10代です
すごく簡単にできるので皆さんもぜひ高知に帰ったらやってみてください
大きな紙に今自分がやっていることをやらなければいいということをすべて書き出して
みてください
学校のことで運命で仕事のことでもいいですサークルのことを合図飲むと&設けです
とにかく全て書き出してみてください
これは箇条書きでもツリーマップでもどんな形の ok です
すべて書き出したら今自分がやっていてどれくらい楽しいかというものをその書いた
ことからの横に100点満点で書き出してみてください
この100点満点の点数が高ければ高いほど
今自分がやっていて楽しいと感じているもということです
この点数が高いものをピックアップしてそこに少し
包括していけばきっと皆さんお楽しみの最後の詰めで毎日の生活がしたい力になって
いくのではないでしょうか
ただ自分の中の楽しいを信じて
pou dou dou